a joyful sound to mark a moment in
history
[Music]
after more than a century this sacred
african artifact is returning home
it is one of the benin bronzes a
collection of sculptures stolen from
nigeria in 1897 by british soldiers
before being placed in cambridge
now jesus college has put pen to paper
on a historic agreement becoming the
first place to return one
i think we've now begun to realize how
historic it is i mean the the outpouring
of of of uh of contacts and just people
just saying this is fantastic
um you know requests to say look can you
please live stream the ceremony i hope
we do it justice today it is a very
historic day
events like today's will pile the
pressure on other institutions the
british museum holds hundreds of items
that also come from the kingdom of benin
but has not yet committed to returning
them
museums in europe have already begun
deciding how they will face their
imperial past
this exhibition is the last time these
treasures will be displayed in france
while germany became the first country
to agree to hand back their bronzes
earlier this year some historians are
suggesting solutions institutions with
the resources such as the the british
museum should commission replicas of the
pieces they certainly have the skills
and they have the wealth to do it
um and then keep the replicas here and
then return the original pieces to
nigeria
today is much more than a ceremony
it's more symbolic is more significant
and is bigger than all of us here
it goes back centuries
people here have spent years picturing
today's milestone
passionate speeches like this one a
reminder they see this ceremony as part
of something bigger for african
countries trying to recover works
pillaged by european explorers and
colonists this handover is just the
start shinki marike sky news